can't hit the three mellow nice job
going
up high to make sure portland secured it
lillard
no conscience damian lillard will
take shots and make shots from anywhere
on the floor
39 lillard hanging three
damian lillard got it and they're gonna
have to get
porzingis up you see how far back
porzingis is
on that glass
wow damien lillard's just coming right
off
no resistance to this of his sixth
112 to 107. he's against
five men it's just so easy for lillard i
mean
there's just too much space an easy one
over the top
22 for luka doncic the blow-by and the
corkscrew
contact with porzingis free throws
coming porzingis
really having trouble defending on pick
and rolls tonight
lillard his career high is 61. he's got
55.
lillard for three bottom damien
lillard cannot be stopped
mellow looking lillard
five to shoot a minute and a half to
play that's a bomb
oh my god oh ridiculous
damian lillard
it is game time fingers blazer ball
look at how high this thing bounces it
left the frame
[Music]
damian lillard 61 points and portland
61 points back-to-back games of 50-plus
how bad did you want this win tonight it
ain't nothing
when you i told you when i first came i
said i didn't come here to waste my time
i came here they gave us a chance to get
in like we asked for
and that's that's what we're here to do
job still ain't done but i i said
you know what i'm here for we're trying
to get in our work ain't done yet
but we fighting for it